nouvelle semaine pour le journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 bonsoir et
bienvenue voici les titres de ce lundi
16 mars et dimanche 1er tour des
départementales à quelques jours du
scrutin nous continuons notre tour
d'horizon des principaux candidats sur
les cantons avoisinants sur le secteur
de montigny le bretonneux ce sont les
maires de guyancourt et de montigny
justement qui s'affrontent jusqu'au 22
mars une semaine de courtoisie sur la
route se déroule incivilités
comportements dangereux sont pointés du
doigt et notamment cette nouvelle mode
du sel fille au volant une dictée pour
la bonne cause le lion ce club vient
d'organiser la sixième édition de ce
rendez-vous à versailles afin de
récolter des fonds pour permettre le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
et de celles atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer
l'union locale de la cgt de trappes 50
ans dénonce les dépassements
d'honoraires pratiqués à l'hôpital de
trappes et il appelle à signer une
pétition devant les portes de
l'établissement
le collectif craint à long terme la
disparition du service public de santé
sur l'hôpital cette action reprend
l'initiative de l'année dernière il
avait recueilli un peu plus de 1000
signatures on écoute christian à pain et
les membres de l'union locale de la cgt
trappe saint quentin c'est au micro de
mathilde de capvern des dépassements
d'honoraires qui sont pratiquement mais
qui sont devenus lusage il n'y a
pratiquement pas un usager qui sort de
cette clinique sans qu'on lui demande
des dépassements d'honoraires pour les
personnes âgées par exemple qui en 50
euros pour vivre la question qui se pose
et 50 euros c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il
nous faut pour nous nourrir pour la
semaine on a le choix se faire soigner
il y avait des dépassements d'honoraires
ou vivre donc le choix est vite fait les
élections départementales qui approche
et afin de vous aider à faire votre
choix nous vous proposons tout au long
de la semaine de faire le point sur les
principaux duels dans certains cantons
autour de saint quentin en yvelines et
sur saint quentin en yvelines et ce
lundi focus sur le canton de montigny le
bretonneux c'est avec mélanie poker
c'est l'un des rares cantons à ne subir
aucune modification pour ce scrutin une
élection qui s'apparente à un duel de
poids tueur avec la présence de deux
mers le binôme socialiste voit se
présenter françois de ligne et maire de
guyancourt et conseiller général sortant
je vais prendre un exemple celui
d'éducation puisque j'étais dans la
commission éducation et que j'étais
également au conseil départemental de
l'éducation nationale et j'ai agi pour
défendre le système public d'éducation
des exemples pour les moyens pour les
collèges les six collèges publics de
notre canton ou obtenu des moyens en
terme de travaux et de rénovation et
puis pour l'université j'ai obtenu le
schéma départemental pour les résidences
étudiantes élu en 2008 dès le premier
tour françois de ligne et s'associe
cette année à elle sandrine grand gambe
première secrétaire fédérale du parti
socialiste est suppléante du maire de
vian courtois aux cantonales de 2008
le binôme conscient des difficultés
vécues par la gauche actuellement axés
principalement sa campagne sur l'action
sociale le logement et les déplacements
le conseil général s'occupe de de la
question du handicap il a aussi il ya
énormément de de défaillance et il ya
des dossiers apporter pour éviter que
des familles soient obligés de voir
leurs enfants partis en belgique parce
qu'il ya juste pas les places
nécessaires ici la question des
personnes âgées aussi je pense qu'on a
une population qui vieillit on n'a pas
assez pris en compte le vieillissement
de cette population comme lors des
dernières élections départementales
c'est michel laugier maire de montigny
qui se présente pour la droite c'est
vrai que l'on peut résumer cette
élection le maire de montigny contre le
maire
il y encourt le conseiller général
sortant contre le président de
l'agglomération oui effectivement c'est
vrai que sur le papier c'était de beaux
duels sauf que déjà les pédants duel
puisque nous sommes 4 a besoin de plus
de 204 alors maintenant je dire de tous
est celui qui aura
auprès des électeurs la confiance le
président de la casse qui s'associe
cette année avec laurence trochut
conseillère municipale d'opposition de
huy en cours avec pour principaux axes
le social la réussite scolaire et les
aménagements routiers mais axes de
campagne vont être en priorité tout le
domaine de la solidarité de l'action
sociale parce que je pense que vraiment
à l'échelle locale être à l'écouté
de tous ceux qui peuvent nous confier
leurs leurs besoins leurs difficultés et
bien c'est là qu'elle renouveau de la
politique
dans ce canton des autres listes se
présentent sylvain grisons et eugénie la
vigne pour le fn
europe ecologie les verts le front de
gauche s'associe avec olivier parent et
jean emilie germain veut de règne et la
politique c'est aussi mardi avec un
nouveau débat sur ce canton de montigny
le bretonneux justement ce sera à suivre
en direct à partir de est 19 heures
c'était samedi un tout autre sujet à
présent qu avait lieu la dictée annuel à
versailles en événements organisés
depuis six ans par le lions club qui
permet de récolter des fonds pour lutter
contre la maladie d'alzheimer mais avant
tout pour sensibiliser le grand public
avec 80 personnes qui sont venues
participer cette fois ci à son exercice
toujours aussi compliqué
trois jours plus tard
hâbleur thaumaturgique va me proposer il
fut un inconnu alors dans son cru ces
élèves d'un jour découvre avec surprise
leur dicter des mots compliqués ou même
inconnu pour certains d'un texte
original sur la mort du roi louis xiv
lui par une professeur de la sorbonne
paulette lhermitte leclerc là je
participe à cette dictée parce qu'on me
l'a demandé on me l'a demandé pour une
excellente cause qui ne se soucie
aujourd'hui la maladie alzheimer
par ailleurs je me réjouis que de
nombreuses personnes s'intéressent
encore à l'orthographe qui est
aujourd'hui beaucoup pour briller
l'occasion de tester son orthographe
mais surtout de lutter contre la maladie
d'alzheimer organisée par le lions club
de versailles l'intégralité des fonds
récoltés lors de cette journée sera
reversé à cette cause notre but est
d'avoir un support qu'ils soient
cohérents avec nos objectifs une
orthographe la mémoire madila zelmer il
ya une certaine cohérence dans ce genre
d'activité est le média sa mère
voici ce que l'ouverture de centres deux
jours pour la meilleure amer et surtout
destiné à aider l'an le
l'environnement dire l'entourage des
malades puisque les malades eux-mêmes 80
personnes ont répondu présent à l'appel
du professeur et à la fin de l'exercice
on attend avec impatience la correction
j'espère que ce sera plus facile
une lecture
hyper hydros oui vellard je sais pas
quoi devez l'art là je sais pas ce que
heroes thématiques que j'ai écrit un peu
comme comme ça se prononce
elisor je demande et enfin bon il y
avait plein de il y avait les accords
qui était un petit peu compliqué grâce à
ces actions le lion's-club de versailles
a déjà contribué à l'aménagement de deux
centres pour aider les malades et leurs
proches et avant de participer à la
prochaine dictée mieux vaut relire le
dictionnaire
invités de ce 16 mars à présent régis
chomel de jarnieu bonsoir et bienvenue à
plateau vous êtes le président de
l'association française de prévention
des comportements sur la route nous
allons évoquer avec vous cette semaine
internationale de la courtoisie sur la
route c'est jusqu'au 22 mars à qui
s'adresse cette semaine et puis surtout
est-ce que ça va servir à quelque chose
parce que quand on conduit mal ou qu'on
fait pas attention en général on se
moque un petit peu
à qui s'adresse à tous ceux qui voudront
bien se sentir impact est un peu comme
pour arrêter de fumer
mais ensuite calé son quelle est son
utilité l'objectif c'est effectivement
de
d'élever le niveau de conscience de
chacun sur la route on ne fait pas
forcément attention c'est pas forcément
attention et nous sommes tous les
maillons d'une chaîne vertueuse ou non
vertueux quels sont les mauvais
comportements les plus fréquemment sur
la route c'est vrai c'est le clignotant
par exemple les petits détails comme ça
qui est tout à fait important c'est tout
à fait ça c'est le clignotant ce sont
les distances de sécurité c'est le fait
de glisser un stop c'est le fait
d'encombrés une intersection
et puis et puis la toute première des
dix courtoisie ou des incivilités c'est
tout simplement de ne pas respecter le
code de la route que nos amis québécois
appellent code de la sécurité routière
de manière subliminale l'approché pas la
même voilà forcément l'approché pas la
même en 2012 c'est vinci autoroutes ce
qui avait publié un sondage qui montrait
que les automobilistes n'étaient pas
très fair play sur la route 50 % des
automobilistes un jury leurs voisins 42%
klaxon à tout-va 24% cole délibérément
la roue la route
et que vous décrivez là c'est exactement
ce que vivent par ailleurs les élèves de
l'auto-école que je dirige
et on pourrait hélas tourner un film de
deux heures sur l'enfer d'une auto école
la grande surprise des éviers mais il a
glissé le stop mais il m'a doublé pas un
par dessus la ligne blanche etc etc mais
ce cas une amélioration malgré tout dit
vous dirigez une autre école est ce que
justement avec les plus jeunes vous
voyez
c'est paradoxal de lire mais c'est
effectivement à partir des plus jeunes
que l'amélioration viendra la conduite
abîmée du modèle dominant fait que
malheureusement les adultes considèrent
qu'ils sont bons conducteurs parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu d'accident grande
chance mais par contre quand un jeune
qui est en formation dit à ses parents
maman tu respectes pas les distances de
sécurité papa de la famille tête des
clignotants les parents répondent des
coûts de passe ton permis format la paix
je peux y l'accident au lieu de profiter
de cette opportunité pour se remettre en
question un petit peu et de de reprendre
conscience qu'ils sont en effet un
modèle pour leurs enfants il ya toujours
la question du téléphone au volant
d'ailleurs peut-être une petite
parenthèse téléphone qui a été largement
interdite vous êtes vous contre
l'interdiction complète avec le même les
kits mains libres par exemple où tous
ces autres quelle est votre position
vis-à-vis alors
je suis un peu partagé parce que il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui interdire
totalement ce sera impossible
donc oui éventuellement ou kit bluetooth
est encore sous réserve que l'équipement
dans la voiture permettent de composer
un numéro vocalement par exemple appelé
valérie alors valérien valérie 2 s'il y
en a plusieurs dans le répertoire dans
ce sens effectivement sans doute et
encore parce que comme de bien entendu
on sait que le seul véritable usage du
téléphone il est en gros pour les
commerciaux et les commerciaux sont sur
les autoroutes et sur les autoroutes il
ya un moyen de s'arrêter tous les 20 km
puisqu'il ya station essence aire de
repos stationnant s'arrêter ce sera le
plus voilà le plus sécure pour le reste
tout ce qui est ce m s et c'est
malheureusement un essai mais justement
il ya une autre mode aussi qui
s'installe je l'évoqué en titre tout à
l'heure c'est la question d'aider celles
fille au volant aussi je ne sais pas si
c'est parce qu'effectivement les jeunes
sont contents d'avoir eu leur permis et
qui veulent se mettre en scène qui se
prennent en photo pendant qu'ils
conduisent pourrait faire c'est assez
terrifiant puisqu'on va les premières
statistiques qui émane des
compagnies d'assurances donc enfin il
faut savoir raison garder mais je
rapproche pas d'une question qui lui
était posée récemment par une de mes
élèves qui disent aimer fascistes dans
le petit bouquin ils nous disent que
l'alcool etc etc mais mais on le sait on
a beau le savoir malheureusement on
pense sans doute que il ne nous arrivera
rien ou bien s'agit-il de manière plus
pernicieuse de l'idée que on n'échappera
à des contrôles parce qu'il y en a pas
tant que ça
comment se déroule la semaine justement
parce que là on parle de sensibilisation
vous venez en plateau vont multiplier
les interviews mais concrètement sur le
terrain alors elle se déroule d'abord
grâce aux 2000 communes et 350
associations qui font partie de notre
mouvement et qui s'engagent prenons un
exemple dans les communes ça peut être
la police municipale ça peut être le
conseil municipal des enfants ça peut
être
les aînés à travers la semaine bleue
parce qu'après tout on n'est pas obligé
de mener une action de sécurité routière
uniquement pendant la semaine de la
courtoisie sur la route mais au
contraire on peut faire vivre l'esprit
de la courtoisie sur la route tout au
long de l'année
donc il se passe de multiples actions il
faut pas oublier effectivement les
gendarmeries qui parfois vont dans les
lycées avec les
lunettes laser pour montrer aux jeunes
comme c'est facile de repérer celui qui
roule à 70 au bout de l'avenue tout ça
dans un objectif de pédagogie et pas
seulement pédagogie de la règle mais
pédagogie aussi du risque et c'est en ça
que c'est intéressant et peut-être si
vous le permettez à ce ça je voudrais
rappeler la véritable définition de la
courtoisie sur la route c'est pas
seulement l'amabilité supposé régné à la
place des noms d'oiseaux dans les
usagers dans les échanges entre de ceux
qui sont sur la voie publique en réalité
la courtoisie sur route c'est un concept
qui s'appuie sur la notion de causer de
conséquence votre m'indique ce que je
fais ou pas qui créent ou non de la
sécurité sur la route et puis c'est
aussi le principe de responsabilité
individuelle parce que les pouvoirs
publics ont raison de dire sécurité
routière tous responsables mais en
réalité et je reprends ce que dit tout à
l'heure comme pour arrêter de fumer en
matière de sécurité routière on est tous
responsables chacun et ça va un tout
petit peu plus loin et à la possibilité
aussi peut-être d'obtenir ce petit guide
voilà ça brille pas trop c'est un petit
guide de la courtoisie sur la route on
peut se rendre sur le site internet
commandé avec ce qu'il faut pour bien se
conduire sur la route juste un dernier
mot très rapidement là aujourd'hui c'est
une semaine internationale qui se
déroule dans les autres pays on est plus
courtois sur la route alors il faut
s'entendre on sait que culturellement on
est plus courtois y compris au sens
conceptuel que j'ai de l'élite à l'heure
dans les pays anglo-saxons et de
l'europe du nord malheureusement
l'europe du sud non si vous permettez
étant donné que ce vendredi samedi
dimanche aura lieu un salon qui
s'appelle le salon vivre autrement au
coeur duquel on anime un espace conduire
et se déplacer autrement j'invite le cas
échéant voter les spectateurs à venir
nous rencontrer il ya des simulateurs de
conduite il ya des quizz il ya des jeux
pour toutes les générations et puis il y
aura également la remise des prix en
tout cas au lauréat français du festival
mondial du film de sécurité routière et
monsieur le préfet de police de paris
nous a fait l'honneur de sa présence
puisqu'en effet un policier motard sera
récompensé pour certaines actions qui là
qu'il a développée de manière
audiovisuelle donc voilà c'est un grand
rendez-vous pour l'ensemble des
habitants de l'île de france le rendez
vous qui est lancé merci régis chomel de
jarnieu le président de l'association
française de prévention des
comportements sur la route semaine
internationale de la courtoisie c'est
jusqu'au 22 mars merci à vous un mot de
ce sport à présent en football magny les
hameaux qui se rapproche encore un peu
plus de la montée en première division
district ce dimanche les hommes de farid
gagnante étrillé le pecq sur leur
terrain score final 7 buts à 0 pour les
manies qu avec quatre passes décisives
de l'attaquant nicolas rouillon le
passeur était au micro de tv fil 78 donc
je crois que les troisièmes il aura fait
du mal ils ont beaucoup lâché derrière
après on avait beaucoup d'espacés on a
joué intelligemment ne reste en place
derrière n'est pratiquement pas été en
danger à part sur une frappe à la fin
sinon je vois je crois qu'on est resté
bien en bloc et on les a laissés se se
détruire petit à petit le troisième ça
leur a fait du mal psychologiquement
chance on a creusé le trou après et pour
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end
des différentes rencontres dans les
différentes disciplines rendez vous dans
quelques instants sur étaient les fils
comme chaque lundi avec mitel et demi
d'euros et le 7-8 sport le journal
revient quant à lui demain aux mêmes
horaires excellente soirée